the United States is so obsessively
protective of its currency that guards
its security right down to the specific
fibers that comprise each bill US
currency may be the most counterfeited
money in the world
mccrane paper here in Dalton became the
supplier of paper for US currency in
1879 held that contract ever since that
we are now the sole supplier of currency
paper for the US government crane paper
is special because of the materials that
we choose high quality natural fibers
cotton and flax fibers which has
traditionally been used in textile
making are still used for US currency as
opposed to ordinary papers made today
with wood pulp
a lot of clever people that work hard to
try to create counterfeit security
features in the $100 note include a
watermark feature with the portrait of
Benjamin Franklin which is put in the
paper making process and then the most
prominent security features now the 3d
ribbon here Western world and we are
accustomed to credits and digital
electronic transactions but one of the
features of currency paper of horses and
annuity I think that's partly why is
valued by many around the world they can
adducts
transaction using money without having
traceability to it so a lot of the world
is still realized on this tangible
product paper is money
[Music]